este círculo está dividido en partes
iguales
ok aquí tenemos un círculo dividido en
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez partes iguales y nos
preguntan qué fracción de la
circunferencia o sea del borde exterior
la circunferencia lo podemos pensar como
el perímetro pues del círculo está
resaltada en rosa bueno pues justo como
tenemos diez partes iguales entonces
este cachito rosa es una décima parte de
todo el perímetro porque el perímetro
también queda dividido en uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
partes iguales de esta forma la fracción
de la circunferencia es un décimo le voy
a poner aquí un décimo y luego nos dicen
un círculo completo tiene 360 grados
cuánto mide el ángulo y el ángulo a es
este ángulo de aquí justo es el ángulo
que corresponde a este arco de
circunferencia entonces mide exactamente
una décima parte
voy a poner así una décima parte de 360
que también lo podemos escribir como 360
entre 10 entre 10 y haciendo la cuenta
360 entre 10 nos quedan 36 entonces
vamos a comprobar respuesta muy bien